salvador es un ingeniero civil quiere
ser un dibujo a escala de una cuadra la
cuadra es un cuadrado con área de ocho
mil cien metros cuadrados hace el dibujo
a escala usando un factor de 0.1 muy
bien nos están diciendo que la cuadra es
un cuadrado y nos están dando el área y
en un cuadrado el que sea aquí voy a
dibujar un cuadrado si tenemos que uno
de los lados csl entonces el otro lado
también sl y el área es l al cuadrado y
lo que nos están diciendo es que l al
cuadrado en este caso justo es 8.100
8.100 entonces como le haríamos para
encontrar la longitud de la cuadra en la
vida real
bueno pues tendríamos que encontrar la
raíz cuadrada de 8.100 y de donde
podemos sacar la raíz cuadrada de 8000
8.100 bueno pues una muy buena pista
está aquí en el 81 en el 81 porque
sabemos que 9 por 9 es igual a 81 a 81
si queremos obtener
dos ceros necesitamos agregar 0 saca 90
por 90 es igual a 8000 8.100 y entonces
el lado de la cuadra en la vida real
aquí voy a dibujar este la cuadra el
lado en la vida real es de 81 81 no
perdón es de 90 metros ajá 90 lo voy a
poner acá 90 metros y acá también 90 90
metros ok entonces que tendríamos que
hacer para hacer un dibujo a escala
usando un factor de 0.1
bueno pues cada uno de estos lados lo
tenemos que multiplicar por 0.1 de este
modo en el dibujo a escala lo voy a
poner aquí un poco más chiquito pero no
tan chiquito como como debería ser
tenemos que multiplicar cada uno de los
lados por 0.1 y haciendo eso nos quedan
lados de 9 metros 9 metros acá
9 metros acá si queremos hacer este
dibujo en este esquema que nos ponen
aquí entonces lo que tendríamos que
hacer es medir 9 unidades
aquí ya nos miden 6 faltarían 3 1 2 3
voy a agarrar este color azul es más lo
voy a copiar 1 2 3 el punto tendría que
quedar por acá luego aquí también 1 2 3
el punto tendría que quedar por acá 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y el último punto debe
quedar por acá de esta forma el cuadrado
que se forma y de esta forma el cuadrado
que se hace para que no suene tan feo
sería este de acá y ese sería nuestro
dibujo a escala donde cada uno de los
lados tiene longitud de 9 metros
entonces le pongo aquí 9 metros y acá
también 9 metros